all right talk to us about uh another
person who's done this really well joe
rogan why has joe been so successful in
building what now seems to be a dominant
mainstream platform uh to help people
learn and get the news out there
so you know it's it's funny whenever
people ask me about rogan uh because
it's actually not ideological at all joe
just monetized and built an audience
around several different facets of his
personality and not enough people
actually think about it like this joe
the joe rogan experience and i know this
i've been listening to joe way before i
ever got on the podcast i was a fan when
i was like 23 riding the metro and i was
broke as hell okay so like i literally
was in the actual demographic here's
what joe is he is several different
shows all in one ufc hunting fitness um
like alternative politics now
alternative science bro science and also
wacky conversations that you have when
you smoke too much weed like com and
comedy obviously being the core base of
all of that when you stack all of those
together and you bundle it up into a
single thing you get the joe rogan
experience that's what i think that
everybody misses whenever it comes to
joe which is joe i mean if you actually
listen to the show
there's not a lot of politics on it
yesterday he had on an mma fighter the
time before the day the episode before
that was a a woman who was a lawyer and
now does spear fishing for a living and
i found it pretty interesting but it's a
lifestyle culture show and the reason
why
he can sneak in dissident voices and
dissonant news and get the information
out there is because he has built up
trust over over a decade and that's what
these cnn people don't have i mean how
many times have you and i and everybody
watch them lie
in our with our own eyes and they never
apologize they never retract what
they're saying there's not even a
mechanism to force it i've seen joe
screw up pretty bad and he does a video
which he posts out on his instagram he's
like hey everybody i screwed up i
shouldn't have said this x y and z or
apologize for it on a show and you know
that's a lesson i've learned too i do a
segment almost every six months called
everything i got wrong and i go over
like i'd be like here's what i got wrong
here here's what i got wrong here i did
a rapper on the election where i was
like here are my worst predictions um on
what would happen in november of 2020
people really appreciate that but these
people they're too arrogant to ever even
assume that that you would even notice
that they got something wrong they've
never been wrong what are you talking
about